bonjour louis aliot merci de répondre à
nos questions sur arte france au premier
jour dure qu'on finance vous avez pris
un arrêté municipal autorisant le
maintien de l'ouverture des commerces
non alimentaires du centre ville est-ce
que vous vous sentez dans l'inégalité
écoutez vous savez on est un pays de
droit on a le droit de faire des arrêtés
et la justice sera n seule compétente
pour décider si nos décisions sont
légales ou pas on entend bien tout le
discours qu'il y a autour de ces arrêtés
mais il ya aussi une violation de la loi
et du principe d'égalité en autorisant
certains commerces d'ouvrir et en
interdisant à d'autres et c'est bien là
le problème puisque si on veut jouer la
carte de la proximité
si on veut jouer la carte de la
protection sanitaire éviter la diffusion
du virus
eh bien peut-être faut-il éviter que
tout le monde aille de s'incliner
toujours dans les mêmes endroits
c'est ce que l'on avait pouvoir lors du
premier confinement donc là aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que les commerces et d'un
père kényan fonctionne comme si de rien
n'était non pas du tout l'arrêté a été
émis hier soir mais c'est à compter de
mardi matin
parce qu'il y a quand même je pense un
tas en temps de latence ou j'espère bien
que les ministres répondront aux
attentes des professionnels des
organisations syndicales et
professionnelles et de ses de ces
commerçants qui n'en peuvent plus parce
qu'on oublie de dire que c'est vrai il
ya une crise sanitaire avec des
problèmes médicaux très lourds très
important et ça c'est de la
responsabilité du gouvernement qui aussi
n'a pas pu ou n'a pas su surtout prévoir
la deuxième vague et les moyens à mettre
en oeuvre mais vous avez aussi toute la
problématique économique de père de
famille de mère de famille de deux chefs
d'entreprise qui ont des employés et qui
ont de l'endettement et qui ne savent
pas comment de même ils pourront tout
simplement vivre et survivre jusqu'à
maintenant on a entendu
bruno le maire juste avant votre
votre interview avec un entêtement du
pib qui va s'accroître encore
pratiquement 120% du pib
qu'est-ce que comment est ce que vous
réagissez à ça non mais c'est bien que
l'état accompagne la dette marre ça va
être terrible pour les finances
publiques mais moi j'ai bien écouté
avant que je prenne l'antenne le chef du
service des urgences de l'hôpital bichat
qui a clairement dit les choses
peut-être fallait-il un confinement plus
rigide dans les premiers temps pour
freiner la propagation du virus
mais les demi mesures qui ont été prises
elles fâchent tout le monde et elles ne
permettent pas en tout cas aujourd'hui
on peut pas le dire la progression ou la
régression du virus sur le territoire
c'est bien là le problème
et on voit bien que dans cette matière
comme en matière de terrorisme ou de
lutte contre l'islamisme radical
ce gouvernement n'est pas à la hauteur
il n'ya pas d'anticipation il n'y a pas
de moyens mis en place voilà on est en
train de subir les situations des
situations on vous savez très bien que
gouverner c'est poids mais j'ai pas
l'impression qu'ils prévoient grand
chose louis aliot vous parlez donc de
manque d'anticipation d'impréparation de
la part du gouvernement qu est ce que
vous vous auriez fait peu importe les
décisions on a l'impression que qu'il y
aura toujours des critiques non c'est un
peu de la politique politicienne à la
française même en période de pandémie
mais dit ce virus il nous tombe pas
dessus comme ça du jour au lendemain il
nous est déjà tombé dessus il y à il ya
six mois de cela avec un confinement
très dur on a eu des résultats
on a une expérience on sait très bien ce
que le personnel soignant a subi pendant
cette première vague est là depuis
quatorze fait pour prévoir
éventuellement la deuxième vague comme
le disent
marine le pen était intervenu à
l'assemblée pour demander précisément
qu'il y ait des réunions pour prévoir
pour mettre des moyens pour anticiper
tout ça n'a pas été fait et aujourd'hui
on se retourne et vous désirez vous
auriez fait écouter je suis pas au
gouvernement moi je n'ai pas je n'ai pas
tous les renseignements mais j'aurais
sûrement ouvert des lits d'hôpitaux
j'aurais eu sûrement ouvert des lits de
réanimation j'aurais sûrement chez comme
en italie recruter des infirmières des
médecins
bref j'aurais je me serais mis un état
de
alors pour le coup et de mobilisation
générale tout préserver ce qui peut
l'être mais je n'ai pas attendu comme ça
et bien que ça arrive et de subir la
situation comme le laisse à penser
aujourd'hui le gouvernement avec des
mesures d'urgence face à une situation
qui était somme toute assez prévisible
on ne savait pas quand mais on savait
que ça arriverait en face combien de
réanimation combien d'infirmières
combien de médecins combien d'hôpitaux
sont susceptibles de faire face à cela
at on mobilise et le secteur privé
les cliniques privées combien de lits
d'un à quel endroit et cetera et cetera
il n'y a pas de réponses à ces questions
aujourd'hui pour revenir sur l'arrêté
par rapport aux petits commerçants
vous aviez dit à l'instant vous il ya un
temps de latence que tout cela devrait
se mettre en place mardi mais que vous
attendiez en fait une réponse de la part
du gouvernement c'est à dire c'est un
arrêté symbolique ce que vous avez pris
les préfets qui sont quand même
empressée de demander au maire de les
annuler et souffre sous peine de les
faire annuler devant les tribunaux
administratifs
oui mais justement on ira devant les
tribunaux et on verra bien mais c'est un
arrêté d'alert ce matin j'étais encore à
la chambre de commerce en réunion avec
tous les responsables du monde
économique et tout le monde est au
diapason
oui mais tonnes tous les moyens pour la
crise sanitaire et la préservation de la
santé de nos concitoyens ya pas de souci
là-dessus mais inversement
arrêtons j'allais dire de créer des
inégalités dans le monde économique et
on ne comprend toujours pas pourquoi
dans les grandes surfaces
on continue à pouvoir vendre certain
nombre de produits que l'on ne peut pas
vendre au centre ville ou ailleurs c'est
ça que dénoncent les commerçants c'est
cette distorsion de concurrence
alors qu'à matière sanitaire de
protocole à matière de protection dans
leurs boutiques
ils sont à même de faire face à tout ce
qu'on leur demande il sait ce sujet là
que le premier ministre doit trancher
et pour l'instant l'association des
maires de france les différents
syndicats patronaux les consulaires
sont aussi en demande de ces choses là
eh bien c'était aussi à nous les maires
de leur apporter notre soutien à l'idée
d'attendre que le ministre se prononce
justement vous parlez des mères en
général il ya beaucoup de maires qui ont
pris cette même décision
comme vous à perpignan des mères avec
différentes étiquettes politiques ça
veut dire que qu'on fait ou abstraction
de la couleur politique par rapport par
rapport à cela par rapport à cette
décision mais ça prouve que c'est de
l'intérêt général et que c'est une
émanation de ce que veulent nos
concitoyens parce qu'ils ne sont pas
d'ailleurs vous avez vu dans les
enquêtes d'opinion à toutes les
questions qu'on leur pose
grosso modo oui il faut du confinement
pour éviter que la que la propagation du
virus soit plus soit plus active
mais à la question trouvez vous que ce
soit normal que l'on ferme les commerces
de proximité à 56 % des français disent
non donc on voit bien qu'on est
totalement dans cet état d'esprit qu'on
ne cherche pas à ouvrir pour ouvrir et
pour aggraver la situation mais
clairement que l'on tienne compte du
devenir de la situation de du monde
économique un général pour que à la
misère de la crise sanitaire ne viennent
pas s'ajouter demain la misère du monde
économique avec des conséquences
dramatiques pour beaucoup
merci oui au lieu d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
maire et rennes ii perpignan